hi everyone it's Jerry I have another
group of five puzzles that I'd like to
share with you in each of them it's
white to play and it's up to you to
determine what the best continuation is
so let's you can go five for five out of
these
this right here is puzzle one go ahead
pause the video see if you can find the
best continuation for white okay the
solution to puzzle one is a checkmate in
three starting first with Queen g7 King
takes Queen Knight f5 is double check
both bishop and Knight hitting the king
and double check the king must Ollie's
move in this case King Jade is the only
legal response and now Knight to h6 is
checkmate as well as Knight to e7 so
whichever of these two highlighted
squares is your favorite both is a
solution to puzzle number one so I'm
moving on to the second one once again
white to play pause the video see if you
can find the best continuation for white
okay the solution to puzzle number two
is a checkmate in five starting first
with Queen to b7 forcing rook takes
Queen knight c6 check forcing the King
in the corner and after rook to e8 black
has nothing better than to just delay
the inevitable with rook blocks rook d8
we just capture the rook rook b8 we just
capture the rook the knight and rook
alone are setting up and mating that to
this black king so this is checkmate for
puzzle number two moving on to the third
one let's have a look at that okay white
White's a play in this position as well
go ahead pause the video see if you can
find the best continuation for white ok
the solution to puzzle number three is
rook to d8 taking into account that the
black Queen can't go too far because if
Queen takes rook we have Queen f8
checkmate in fact one of the things to
really recognize in this position and
this is something that you could really
just look - whenever you're confronted
with some chess puzzle and that is to
recognize the constraints that you have
on your opponent's position more
specifically the pieces what what sort
of constraints are there for example on
the black queen in this position
unfortunately she's constrained in a
great way
she has two roles neither of which she
really wants to have and that is to
watch over f/8 as well as d8 both both
are guarding against maybe rook to d8 or
Queen to f8 so with this in mind we can
try to use the tactic of deflection and
that's essentially how you can describe
this rook to d7 move trying to deflect
the black Queen away from defense of f8
so if if the Queen went to e6 then we
would have the rook going to d8 leading
to mate so maybe the best continuation
at this point is going to e 8 but that
now runs into Queen f6 check King g8 and
now rook to d8 winning the Queen is
equivalent to essentially winning the
game at this point so the solution to
this one was pretty much rook to d7 and
recognizing that this would be the
continuation should the Queen take the
rook okay moving on to the fourth one
let's have a look at that puzzle number
4 once again white to play in this
position see if you can find the
solution to this one okay the answer to
puzzle number 4 is rook captures Bishop
and if the Queen doesn't take the rook
back black is simply down a full piece
so after Queen takes rook Queen takes on
g6 check taking into account that this
pawn is pinned to the king there is no
pawn takes Queen and if the King were to
go in the corner that's going to lead to
mate
starting with Queen takes pawn King g8
rook g1 and after the Queen blocks we
capture the Queen with our rook or at
least that's one way to go ahead and win
the game from this position however
maybe the more difficult thing to have
foreseen is that the King doesn't have
to go to g8 but it could play the black
Queen could play to g7 and there is a
very key move at this point which is
Queen to f5 a very quiet move and now
it's setting up two very strong threats
one first and foremost is rook to g1
rook to g1 which would place the Queen
and a pin but not only that there's also
the idea of
setting up a battery along this diagonal
once the bishop is placed on e4
for example if King H a rook g1 and if
the Queen tries to find the safe square
to go to like Queen D for Bishop b4 now
how to meet the threat of mate on h7 so
there's really no satisfactory defense
at this point the black queen is going
to be having to give herself up probably
best at this point to just give the
Queen up for the rook so really this is
the key move knowing that this this
Queen to f5 move a few moves down the
line is really a key ingredient to
solving this position right here
one other thing to know about this
position is that after if you were to
have tried rook to g1 in this position
that's that's not the best continuation
because after Queen to h4 even though it
looks a little bit scary after rook
takes g6 after King goes in the corner
what's the what's the continuation at
this point unfortunately black is
threatening mate on h2 and this rook is
just going to have to come back
passively to just to this g2 square one
one other continuation to be aware of is
that after rook takes Bishop Queen takes
rook Queen takes Queen blocks Queen f5
this rook lift rook to a6 doesn't work
either because the the white rook could
still play to g1 and still you have to
take into account that this pawn is
pinned to the king so we could just have
rook takes on g6 this is just bad news
for black so moving on to the last
puzzle puzzle number 5 let's have a look
at that one okay white to play in this
position go ahead pause the video see if
you can find the best continuation for
white ok the solution to this one is
actually a checkmate and six all of
these moves are forced or I should say
all the black moves that you see are
only moves black only has one response
in each instance so we start out first
with Queen takes Knight King takes Queen
rook check King g6 rook check
age six forcing King to g5 h4 check King
G for Knight e3 check King g3 and
finally ripped to f3 and that's
checkmate so this King went for a nice
little stroll ended up on g3 and white
is able to finally just finish black off
with this rook to f3
checkmate move so be sure to let me know
how you did on these puzzles let me know
if they were too easy too difficult and
also how you did so that's all for this
video hope you got something out of it
take care bye